he's performing tonight Webster Bank
Arena in Bridgeport Connecticut is a big
arena yes let's see I've played on this
tour some insanely huge places where
there's some I show up and I go look at
this and it's just filled with a massive
amount of people notice I'm I show up
and I go woof that hurt what is it like
when there's not a big audience oh
that's just a mind game you know you
just you just can you ignore it
you just look forward to them turning
the lights down alright so Sandman has
got his Comedy Tour wait what does this
call is this 100% fresh 100% fresher
fresh earth that's the tour name and I
got five left I got tonight
and then tomorrow Jersey then Atlanta
then Florida and Florida Tampa and st.
Augustine you have my god and then
you're done yes they do
who loves you like where's the plate
where's the heartland of Sandler
I don't know Minnesota we we always we
always it's always nuts in Minnesota New
England's always nuts
New York's is always pretty strong I
don't know man it's all it's all but
Florida every time we do shows down
there those guys they just have so much
fun living in Florida they just show up
extra extra excited who told you you
were funny my father always said I was
funny I was trying to be funny my
brother my brother Scott yeah he's the
one who told me to be a comedian and you
have an older brother that tells you
that that yes and you know that's pretty
that's that authenticates that right
when you have that he had my back on
because it could go the other way we'd
say you know you think you're funny or
not that's what you get a real job oh my
god I didn't have that at all I had a
the youngest in the family my two
sisters thought I was nice and funny and
everything I said was good my they came
to my show might one sister saw me in
Vegas two weeks ago she thought I was
she cries during my shows all these
people are here for you
and then my sister Elizabeth who saw me
in Massachusetts the other night and she
was like so happy and what he sounds
surprised that you're funny I think no
they just surprised that all these
people come and see the show and my
mother by the way never she was at the
one in Mansfield Massachusetts yeah she
just sat in the dressing room for the
two hours until I was done and then was
she nervous or didn't want to know she
want to hear the my father told her a
long time ago how disgusting I am I
don't need to hear that I don't want to
hear that and then but my brother walked
around her and I sang the red hooded
sweatshirt song and I do a quick version
of that and she came out and saw it on
cheese and there's no curse words and
that's what she was at how good are you
as a guitar player against a real guitar
player um but could you be a rhythm
guitar player it may be my crush on
stage and you played a song I could play
a song like anybody
what could you play I could play
anything what do you want to be like
Dave Matthews invites you up could you
play I could crash or something like yes
yes I do sing with like Damon I could do
fine I could do fine one sound as good
as him but I would I could do if I you
know I could I could jam with anybody
but I'm not if I was making an album the
the guy recording yeah we're gonna go
like lose that guy cuz I'm at a time a
lot and I make some weird noises and and
it's but I'm not like when I play with
the real guys yeah they kind of smirk at
what I'm doing but if it's of any
benefit Eddie Van Halen's not funny yeah
he's pretty wait you've been out with
Eddie man I know Eddie man wait Eddie
when he was drinking her Eddie sober I
think I think I know both it he's yeah
yeah and I know what smooth they're on
the guitar than that guy he's pretty
pretty good he came by my office a few
times and we hung out and he I had an
electric guitar he plugged
he didn't even plug in he just had it he
was screwing around with it and of
course all of a sudden I just said the
word eruption to try to meet him down
there
was the best would you trade your career
for Allan Houston's career you know what
he's I would love to be as good as him
in the sport but no you know I think
Eddie Van Halen is more the way I would
be if I said you could be Eddie Van
Halen if I had the skill of Eddie Van
Halen yes I would take that you would
cash in what you're doing now I know you
get to keep your wife and kids I I know
I like what I got I like what I got but
I would I do admire that more than what
I do
are you a show-off and mcc's itíd when
guys come over to jam it but you like to
perform like y'all know cuz some guys
don't like they're good at it but they
get you know they eats them up a little
bit in song it's me up for sure is it
when I would do Super Bowl or Olympics
or something of that magnitude even
though this was my job it eat me up a
little bit of course yes you keep going
why did I say yesterday well because
it's just nerve-racking you want it to
be great and you're supposed to enjoy it
and you can't tell somebody hey I'm not
enjoying this no because I want it to be
great I know I know it's her own head I
definitely this this tour I am having
the best time ever on stage during this
tour as you said you're away from your
wife and kids and you're having a great
time first question for Adam Sandler oh
great performing tonight the Webster
Bank Arena in Bridgeport Connecticut
some seats still available I don't know
if they are not but probably come and
get him here we go Paul Adam you've been
doing the Chris Farley tribute song for
I think a couple years now and on your
show yes it got really popular when it
went viral this year the first time you
did it on stage what was that like
moving I was I think I might have played
it for the first time at in LA at a
small club there Largo and the crowd
response was overwhelming I remember
that remember
everybody immediately loved talking
about him scene O'Conner so your movies
lately are dealing a lot with sort of
like the dynamics of couples right
husband and wife and family and things
like that and there's a scene in murder
mystery where and I think it's okay that
I say this I'm not giving away too much
dies in the end don't say that okay
where Jennifer Aniston who plays your
wife is sort of talking about things
that you're something that you're not
very proud of with you failed your yes
my test your test not a detective right
and you say like well she's got the you
know acid reflux and you know yeah
that's really funny
when's the last time that you wrote
something into a movie that you were
like I better clear this with the missus
first well that's a good one I if I have
that thought in my head
I usually just run away but in that
scene in the beginning of the movie she
says and I'm not sleeping with the fan
on tonight yes she says that to me
that's that's stolen from my life this
is a nightly fight about the fan do you
need to fan on it no see I need the
noise of the fan no one else I need the
noise of the fan and apparently it's too
colder than my wife's but then you say
something about the the lights on or she
wants the we're talking about the murder
yes I want the lights on that's right
yeah that's you want the lights on I'll
put the lights on that was written by a
Vanderbilt he wrote that line of fritzy
most nervous you ever were during your
SNL days whether it was in front of
Lorne Michaels or someone that you were
somehow intimidated by that you thought
was just so great where you're like I
don't know if I'm gonna be able to hack
it with this group of that go I don't
think I ever thought about the group I
only thought I was terrified every
episode every time I did the countdown 5
4 I would always have some crazy thing
that was going through my brain no no I
was never I can't we go all right but
when you do opera man or like it feels
like it's the commitment to the
character that makes it funny yeah you
know what the last time I did it when I
hosted the show yeah that's the first
time
when they would count down on the show
that I went oh this is gonna be fun and
I think I'd probably just cuz I might
well I have some of them my wife kept
saying just have fun and there's people
are here they're on your side quit
thinking everyone's against you that
kind of thing and and this this girl I
know for many years right before I went
out there she as a stage manager of the
show she she pointed to this thing
before you go out on SNL and it says
something like just have fun or have a
good time or something like that I
wouldn't you have man let me just enjoy
this and I per man then when I was going
out I I remembered you see in the
audience and being in the goofy costume
again and no one I'm 52 years old and
how stupid it was and I was wearing that
wig and the cape and all that I said let
me just but it's a home court advantage
for you yeah you're right I felt really
at ease that night there McLovin okay
I'm gonna go a little serious out of the
headlines yes
our traditional movies in trouble
because of streaming services mm-hmm I
that as totally doesn't fit anything
that's been talked about today but with
your deal with Netflix I was curious
yeah I don't I don't know I think the
right movie makes it anywhere and and
then that's been the case and and I
remember when you signed this deal Yeah
right before you did and you were like
nervous like you were a mess yeah you
were and then you're like uh you know
I'm not sure a guy and then you sign the
deal and then you were like a different
man and I think people you don't read
this but they were critical of like what
are you doing with your career you just
signed it away to Netflix right right
and you knew exactly what you were doing
we were ahead of the curve
feels great now and it did feel relief
back then I was like first they they
look they were so Ted so randoms were so
nice to me and so excited about making
movies that felt good and and just the
amount of people were telling me
throughout the last four years how much
Netflix they watch and that's where they
watched a movie so that made my life
what's your biggest box-office success
that made the most money all those Hotel
Transylvania movies they get most and
then grownups I think made the most more
than long assured maybe worldwide ok the
most yeah and then I get I still get
more reaction to water boy oh yeah I get
when I go on the tour I get happier more
water boy yeah we got we got water boy
gear like a year ago from adidas yeah
they sent me jerseys yeah 20th
anniversary yes yes and when I do my
concerts all these kids you know show me
the shirt and they were also wear The
Longest Yard Jersey and yeah I know that
was Burt Reynolds movie so I always feel
and Dan covered for you on that one that
was good yeah I normally do like when he
doesn't give a good answer
and I'm always there to say what Adam
means to say yeah that's right yeah so
you can watch the three on you know this
is gonna be televised on the DP show out
well yes and I have to say even in
warm-ups out there when the cameras I'm
not excited about the okay I'm thinking
of putting seating on you yeah he's
athletic he's younger than you yeah
he's not afraid he doesn't care who you
are he could yep now do you want fritzy
guarding you know I saw a pretty Justin
warmers in it that's the kind of guy
who's gonna get me hurt emotionally yes
hook shot to the face absolutely love it
I can't cover Vesey I mean the only
chance is if he crosses me over and I'm
still standing now what do you want
Seaton to guard the ringer and you guard
Sandler because they got locked they got
a big guy in there and I Loughran makes
a lot of heat makes a lot of room he's
just wrong you're gonna be he's gonna be
a pain in your butt a lot of us are
worried about causing any kind of facial
harm to Adam before he has to perform
tonight and I'm a little gawky so I'm a
little encore de maybe see me be better
yes
Pauling excisions shaylen do we have to
sign a waiver with anyone Netflix yes
yes yes that's fine that's I got it
Larkin's got all the paid
for but okay alright that's funny yeah
see I kind of feel like we all deserve
the opportunity to get embarrassed by
the ringer the ringer will get you yeah
yeah yeah you should switch up on the
ring I want to cover both of you guys
actually happen it's gonna be fine how
long do we play for um we could do two
ten minute halves is that I want to get
a sweat because I have been eating a lot
I know I mean I don't Yankee game last
night I couldn't stop eating wait you
went to the Yankee I saw the game I was
there and in in in the greatest box ever
mom why is it I'm always like I'm always
here you wouldn't have come I wouldn't
have but it would have been nice for you
to invite me this was my life to chase
down all the wifing by the way I sat
with the this nice kid Jack Hughes from
he just got a the other number one pick
unbelievable kid yeah unbelievable kid i
sat with him and then old Reggie Jackson
came over that was pretty good yeah it
would have been nice you would have
loved it yeah you gotta have the kid
Jackie was on the show he's a smooth
sweet kid I think we reached out to him
yes McLovin did you have something to
say you were seeking before we take a
break here yeah we don't we don't like
these matchups we might have to rethink
our whole defense no no this is just a
next thing this is just for the fans to
see how great Sandler is he he plays all
the time like he should be really really
really good will be solid as a rock
yeah I will but I gotta tell you my
piano players here - he's a bull old Dan
bulla if you warned Vesey to sit down
for a few minutes bring him in okay
alright we ready to take a break here
and then you guys are got you got to get
dressed
Sandman you're already always ready yeah
I know and we we have lunch afterwards
on our Trager girls out there we have we
have some barbeque Snider
where is Schneider by the way he thought
he was gonna come out I know maybe she
should ref I felt really bad cuz Sandler
can I say this
yeah yeah Sandler goes hey can you get
Rob Schneider on the show with me and I
go well there's only one seat only one
charity and then he had to go tell later
cuz and I felt bad for head was down
here's the bad part I didn't tell him
these
he's so mad right now we'll take a break
you could watch the three on three it's
an all-star game is what we're calling
it stamps against the yeah something off
your guy yeah the wealthier guys you
heard me Wow Wow yeah you are
yeah my so of those guys believe me they
are vests he's got all his father's
money
you know father gives him all the money
he ever doesn't have any money
oh yeah I'm telling he's got more than
you think he invested in and weed years
ago all right we'll take a break we'll
come back close up shop here you can
watch on the DP show up at 12:30 Eastern
back after this in the Dan Patrick show
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]